thing right and then like my neighbors
across they yeah I'm not in a mansion
like you people and then they uh they
don't have a mansion I'm building one
they put their trash and I'm outside
their door
you know and I can see it on my on my
cam you know and so like
I called the manager oh man yeah I was
like real Karen over here oh yeah yeah I
pay a lot of rent money I don't pay I
don't pay this amount of rent to see
this trash to see trash in front of my
door like yo wait they said it in front
of me they said it in front of you it's
in front of their door but I can see it
across we have like a courtyard and what
should they do take your trash out oh
you because the plan is you take the
trash all the way out and there's like a
trip bin or whatever no it's it's in the
it's in the parking you go down and you
put it just put it right they're just
leave it in your house until you take it
I think they have a dog and they're just
like oh we don't want but that's that's
your business throw the dog out that's
what I'm saying is this like I I don't
it looks like so I killed it up I don't
like when people make excuses like oh
they have kids yeah yeah oh and they
have a dog like no then that just that's
your extra responsibility that's not
mine yeah you know what I mean like you
like I just don't like yeah you're
ruthless but I get it you have a code
that's the code and honestly man I don't
want to be my neighbor I know but it
works out yeah but if I'm your neighbor
and you got you know it'd be like you
don't put your your trash things away
because like it's like rats and raccoons
and stuff come and like whatever like
it's disgusting but but are they leaving
the trash out like all day all night or
yeah I shouldn't get it no problem it's
not I don't know we got a Karen over
here
and then he's like hey they left it out
again oh he got footage oh it's amazing
hey are you the are you Jeffrey Dahmer's
neighbor are you the black lady from the
series uh oh yeah but because that was
me that was bad she told on him so yeah
um he's all snitch yeah yeah no
snitching he's [ __ ] got heads in his
freezer but also house but also for how
many you see nothing dog but also from
how many years how many years
to smell like dead bodies like oh it's
just pork chops that makes sense yeah
dumbass okay I I
yeah yeah I yeah it so he started with
the car thing and now you're saying with
the trash thing the trash is knowing
it's if it's all this disgusting it's
disgusting rats and it smells bad on
eyesore yeah to say the least
dog right so they come back from walking
their dog in their little poop bag they
put that in front of their door too okay
so I have that's disgusting so I have a
I have a I have a uh I have a I have a
question okay do you think and this is
something I've I've grappled with uh
I've I've I'm not sure of myself I I
have not you know I like to have
um
figured out right
um
if
something happens like this like with
the trash thing is your first move to
ask the neighbor yourself or is your
first move to call the management and
now you said you called the management
no no no no no no I I I you segment I
Didn't Do It Like immediately because it
was one of these kinds of things I go I
come home it's like oh the trash is
there all right then you're like all
right I understand one time I get that
you know where like the trash is there
all day right going into the next day
I'm like that's just lazy yeah so my
thing is like if they're making this
choice I don't need to go talk to them
about like because they're already
making a choice that this is how they
want to live now let me let me let me
color a different way is it a guy and
girl yes a couple that matters none but
let me let me well he might have
problems on his hand oh like a guy yeah
I guess like what yeah yeah yeah come
get some Fred Flint okay so it's like
going to HR all right look here's the
deal no no here's the thing Chris but I
know you wanna but let me just okay
I'm simmering but it's fine this is my
home
yeah so like now I don't want to have to
go
and be like now we have a situation
every time we come back we're like hey I
don't I'm just trying to yeah yeah
I agree agree yeah agree agree we are
leaving there that's how I did that
and I think that you know look at the
window and did it fix it but the third
time did it take a picture with their
with their number third time so it
didn't figure yeah no they didn't okay
well then because that's the thing about
this place too is like nobody cares
right you know so I'm like so now where
are you living North Hollywood I'm gonna
find a nice way when I see them to be
like hey uh oh right okay got it well
but they deserve that they deserve that
hey uh you know yeah how much it's
expensive right yeah yeah you know I
mean like I don't think we should have
trash outside yeah yeah it'd be nice if
you didn't leave it out here all night
oh I like that yeah you know but I you
know you you would think that like with
the manager hits you with the hey guys
it's part of the lease you're not
supposed to happen yeah yeah yeah these
people are just like yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] up you know what you should do
just go one night late at night to go
build a little shed around it
Rachel's always like let's just leave
our trash there too oh that's good she's
gangster dude
just go out there and take pictures of
it and take the trash back like for
Halloween but then everyone's gonna
leave their trash no
you now you get it
yeah
[Music]